gang we're adding 20 new cities to that
state trashy tour for the fall and the
winter and you're not going to want to
miss it so come out and see the boys
yeah gang all tickets are going to be
available on Tuesday June 27th at Ru
garbage.com we're doing some bigger
venues that have a pre-sale so if it
asks for a pre-sale code use code
garbage get your tickets are your
garbage.com let's party gang
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage it's that little show
we sit there with your favorite
comedians and we find it at the group to
be classy just a big old piece of trash
I'm your host stage Foley coming at you
on a beautiful day we're out back here
with hoodies in the new edition baby she
is enjoying the summer getting her free
cup of coffee at Wawa good for her she
gets one every day okay she's stealing
it sure my co-host is coming at you from
right next to me he is the CEO of Ru
garbage he is an international
businessman and he's my best pal in the
whole wide world and I love him and I
don't care who knows it give it up for
KJ Kevin James Ryan what's up everybody
thank you thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate view subscribe
on iTunes full video available on
YouTube as you know those numbers are
cooking then obviously the greatest
website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage gang
it's a [__] party over there check it
out yeah how about a nice quick shout
out to our producer extraordinaire the
magic man makes us all look good works
the ones the twos the threes and the
fours he crosses the t's and he dots the
eyes give it up for T-Bone mcgruffins
Toby McMullen everybody what up dude
what's up pal hey we got one of the
realest dudes in comedy and all time
Storyteller this guy all the time out
the long hair ain't [__] lion gang we
could not be more excited to have her
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guest here with us today for the first
time he is a very funny very prolific
stand-up comedian and Storyteller and
you might have seen him in but not
limited to you got Def Comedy Jam you
got BET's Comic View this is not
happening Gotham Comedy live he's got a
Comedy Central half hour at midnight
Church of What's Happening Now laugh
tracks he has multiple stand-up specials
including last year's the domino effect
which has nine million views over there
on the used tube oh some numbers and he
just dropped a brand new amazing special
the domino effect 2 entitled loss it's
got 1.5 5 million views in just a short
couple of weeks and we couldn't be more
excited to have them here give it up for
Ali Sadiq everybody I thank you for that
amazing you started laughing yeah
somebody said hey
he goes big on the hay yeah
for The Listener we were having a deep
conversation right before that and as
soon as I say action I'm like all right
there we go he turns into AM radio host
real quick because my my hey like I I
start my show with hey but it's very low
and modeling like hey you're like hey
and we're ready
you sound like every White Strip Club
[Laughter]
like every every one that was my dream
job when I was a kid
it was mine too yeah everybody wanted to
work in a trip and then my brother my
little brother actually was a strip club
DJ I tried to get him to stop doing it
I'm like yo stop being these clubs out
late at night with these butt naked
women and and smoking marijuana and then
I started thinking about what I was
saying like no I feel like yeah that's a
great it's the greatest job in the world
what did he say did it live up to the to
the expectations that that a young boy
would have oh yeah yeah if you go on DJ
done deal my brother's Instagram DJ done
deal that's great that is a great name
it is a done deal like he he is not
quitting his job
he's gonna be like a 75 year old man
y'all give it up for Mercedes
[Laughter]
and I say I'ma swing by like it's not
four o'clock in the morning
like where am I swinging from it's not
like I'm getting out the bag on this
then drop off some leftovers you forgot
to give him his birthday present so I'm
like I'm gonna swing through and drop
something I'm running some errands I'll
pop by you working tonight yeah I'm over
there
I gotta grab some dry cleaning nearby
there I'm gonna cruise through real
quick
give us the uh give us the backstory we
know you're a Houston guy yes Houston
guy
um and I do want to say this the the
the new special is unbelievable it's
fantastic it's unbelievable and I I know
when you when you open up you were when
I was listening to it coming in I was
like this is going to be fun because you
were hitting on some things that we hit
on yeah you know what I mean so so give
us give us a scoop here which part of
the scoop
you know people say that tell me about
yourself like well you want to start
at three
let's take it back to the beginning
you're born in Houston born and raised
in Houston born and raised in Houston
okay yeah lived a lot of other places
but born and raised in Houston family
traveled around a little bit I have no
idea why my mom and my dad were both in
Job Corps at the time if y'all even know
what that what Job Corps Job Corps is
like when you just go in the world they
you you you traveling you're a traveling
salesperson like and you damn near in
the military it's like yeah it's like
it's like you in the reserves but you
still not you know it's it's weird it's
a weird sounds real vague connected to
the military it's connected to a lot of
things like you it's like it's like you
Red Cross slash military slash just
randomly living like you're a gypsy
almost what were they doing were they
was it I have no idea but they met they
were both like in their teens 115 116.
okay in a very yeah I'm like what were
y'all doing away from y'all families
trying to figure out why wouldn't you
with your family
yeah so um you know two sisters
um and then my I I I say two sisters
because those are the people who I know
from my mom okay my pops could have been
just my brother is by my dad and then I
have another sister's name Naomi I have
random people who are um just hit me
like hey I gotta be related to you sure
and like like who's your father and they
have his name
they know his name are you related to DJ
done deal
definitely my dad
have you ever heard of Job Corps
it is it's so weird it's I don't know
how many siblings I actually have okay
okay so that's that's welcome to the
show baby this is it welcome to the show
and then and I'm scared I'm almost
scared to do like what new 23 years no
no no that brings up just information
you do not want to see yeah because they
they my mom my mom did it a couple years
ago don't they what happened nothing
ruined Christmas
like and look I was I was on the verge I
was on the verge don't do it man you got
too much to lose I'm gonna do it and
then I'm watching you want to ruin your
day to find out you might be Italian is
that what you want to do yeah you're
Sicilian all right
gotta go back and do all your specials
over again
I'm in Buffalo and I'm I'm watching this
show because I watched them I watched
them um I watched a lot of X-Files and
oh [__] and and stuff that you forensic
file to me I've been cooking on it all
week my wife's been out of town that's
on repeat yo let me tell you forget
about it and forensics I watch so much
of it that the lady who live in my house
was not fixing to call her she she said
are you plotting to kill me I'm like no
but if I wanted to I know how to do it
hey I'm telling you what's not gonna
happen I'm not gonna pull the trigger
right laying right next to you
apparently a lot of women do that one
yeah I don't know I ain't shot himself
like
did you remove your nightgown man so I'm
watching this thing and this lady she's
trying to find her you know if she has
any you know people out there and she
knows her dad but she was adopted and I
guess her daddy telling her mom whatever
so that she does the the 23andMe she
finds out that she has a sister
but the sister is in Vietnam okay so you
already know this is yeah so she goes
and tell my father
um you have a daughter in Vietnam and
then they go through this whole story
I'm like I don't don't I don't know I
used to do overseas
and don't do it I just know this is
it just I know it it was a situation in
Germany man oh God like 20 or 30 years
ago I'm trying to start mailing Deutsche
Marks here
my back child support and [__] in Euros
you don't want to do that man I feel
like if I do it it's just gonna just
something's going on no yeah don't it is
what it is
don't go knocking on doors you don't
want to open
the thing is yes well then you're in
there and then if someone else does it
they it starts it starts linking
everybody together oh no and yeah yeah
you don't want that it's not just like
it doesn't stop at oh I might have a
cousin in Dallas
it [__] Maps out to everybody oh no
yeah now they have a they have a new
thing okay that'll get you that'll get
you all the way down to like the very
core of yo genetic makeup yeah and I
don't buy that that much this one's you
know was related to like King Charles II
and all that kind of stuff I don't know
about all that if you were related to
King Charles it was like decades ago I
don't even think you have no State yeah
you can't you can't be knocking on the
door really like hey hey I'm family it's
me Carl that's what I'd be doing I'm a
goddamn Baron all right man you found
out that you're the Lord of something
else
oh yes I'd be over there yeah oh yeah I
would definitely you'd see me in in
Wales with all the stuff on
and the last the last you heard the last
time you're the last king of Scotland on
the last Prince of Wales
so when your mom and dad had you are you
the oldest no I am the middle okay so
they were settled in Houston they were
settled and they were from Houston no no
no mothers mothers from California from
Louisiana and why did they why can they
settled in Houston I have not oh my
dad's my dad's mother was in Houston
okay my dad's mom was in here yeah she
had moved from Louisiana to Houston and
she was running the um the YMCA okay
very respectable very respect okay oh
learn to swim at a YMCA you learn to
swim in the YMCA I learned how to swim
in in some apartments
getting pushed in by some bad child
some child who probably is in prison for
murder because he didn't even know if I
could swim or not just push me in the
pool oh so you drowning people very
early huh sir that's how you learn
though you know it's like you were
learned with Tara you shouldn't be
learning what your shoes on yeah that
shouldn't be fun
yeah
I think I had on corduroys maybe I think
because you know everybody with
corduroys back then yeah I was like
cement yeah it's like you learn how to
swim in a in a puffy coat you got a
Tommy jacket on you're flowering a
triple fat dude how heavy that is shout
out to Triple fan Goose these are
awesome man everybody what they made
well because everybody wanted one of
those when I was a kid I think they were
made it was goose down right that was
like definitely acoustic yeah the one
with the orange inside yeah that was
like a big thing and then the the
feathers on the outside of the hood
wasn't Ghosts no yeah
that was always so itchy
[Laughter]
um all right so when you're a little kid
your mom and dad you they're they're
together together okay and until up
until I was like maybe three up until
you were three who's who's in the house
oh uh in the house is my mom my dad
um and my older sister okay okay all
right so it's the Fourier yes and then
at three years old your parents split up
okay
they separated but still we're dealing
with each other off and on okay because
I know like five and six he was
definitely in and out right definitely
rare mornings and [__] you're like how
are you doing tonight yeah like what's
up man I thought you were gone and did
he stay in Houston though was he just
saying so he was close by oh yeah he was
he wasn't far because my every birthday
like from six to about
um I'm gonna give it about eight I hated
them birthdays that's when my dad would
um try to use my birthday party to get
back in my mom you know I was seeing
dancing with her he she like
why are you why are you coming to my
birthday party you know you don't do
that with my sister like why are you
using my party so and
okay you're watching your dad trying to
get laid at six is a tough one
just watching your dad strike out like
with a lady that he has two children
everybody pack it in yeah like everybody
is over but he go all out for those
birthdays I'm talking about go all out
like this and and I'm like you you
overdressed with everything man nice
Houston it's hot as [__] take the jacket
off hey man my dad had a full suit on
you know I'm just stopping by
tonight
[Laughter]
man he my followers man he this is a nut
case man which which it made for good
comedy you look good you look good wow
dude you know he wouldn't he would pop
up here and there and you know I
remember he um he beat my stepdad up
this is what we're here for man this is
why we play the game all right so they
split up when does your mom get
remarried it's not remarried just
re-situated sure sure all right very
well
yeah with no marriage back then he was
just like hey we together you're going
steady yeah yeah so about about nine
okay about nine and he comes into the
house or you guys moving he comes in he
comes into the house which is [__]
sucks and why was he not was he not cool
very abusive damn [__] very abusive your
dad tuned them up though like I called
my damn like and told him that he hit me
and my dad came really you had one of
those moments yep holy [__] and then I
remember
the maddest he's ever been in life at me
my step my stepdad at the time they my
dad was whooping his ass and I don't
know why I don't know how what happened
well
um he got my dad got put out the house
and the door was locked and I remember
my dad and this is the most
I think this is the craziest he's ever
it was a low Psychopathic moment he was
he was like because he was trying to get
in back in the house and I remember I
was I was about to doing my dad I don't
know how he even sensed it I was about
to do he was like
unlock the door
and I was like
he's like unlock the door I unlocked the
door my dad came right back in with
whooping my stuff that ass again
[Music]
it's such a great moment it's all right
yeah I do every divorced kid no matter
what the step dad does that's got to be
the fantasy yo my dad's gonna beat your
ass my Dad wait till my dad hears about
this oh yeah his name was Walter
Campbell my dad beat his ass
straight out and I I remember living in
an apartment it was two times that my
dad came over
did you I don't think most people
haven't had a a full out family fight
like a family versus another family we
all together yeah together so that's why
my sister is fighting this girl named
Sean
I don't know how to even get into it my
sister fighting this girl named Sean and
the girl scratched my sister and I push
her I was like stop scratching and fight
because my sister's getting box so I'm
like stop [__] scratching and fight
so when I pushed the girl I'm not even
trying to break it up there I want a
good clean fight so her brother
hits me her brother hit me and we we a
whole boxing family like we all box so
I'm I'm on her brother ass and then your
mom's putting the mouthpiece up and then
his mom comes out and jumps on my sister
my mom comes out and on his mom's ass
boom so they her brother the mom's
brother comes out my stepdad is fighting
his the his mom's brother
I'm saying like the Hatfield and McCoys
so then they dad comes out and jumps on
my stepdad was fighting the the uncle my
dad happens to be coming to the house
he's got a full suit on my mom my dad is
not even scheduled to come to the house
for nothing he's dropping something off
of my sister and he just like oh
right and so he's real smooth like he's
like oh it's a fight like it's like he
don't recognize who's fighting you know
so he sees us he's like oh well [__] and
he jumps on the dead he's like it's a
full-fledged family brawl in these
apartments called Willow Ridge
apartments in Houston off of Maine and
we played out fight and we whooped a
family ass
that's like you've lived movie scenes
dude that's like a Hollywood written man
your dad's showing up it was all right
out of nowhere
come from
it's like something from The Avengers
that's crazy it was cool man I I never
forget it it was the coolest [__] it was
right by the laundromat it was crazy
the last couple of minutes after that
must have been like a couple of high
fives those stories when you all link up
there like you had them in the headline
you guys are all sitting there icing
your knuckles
my mom was like I don't even know what
happened
yeah you [__] fight now gang this
episode is brought to you by better help
calling all the Screwballs out there got
two of us here right here in the room
gang do yourself a favor get a little
online therapy going helps you out I
mean how many times are you doing stuff
for other people what are you doing for
yourselves yeah that's what you got to
ask that's what I'm trying to learn help
me help you baby of course gotta get on
a little online therapy it's good to
talk to somebody it's good to talk talk
it out with somebody sometimes you don't
have a certain specialist in your area
and better help can help with that yeah
gang uh you know I've always said but I
thought guys nuts talk therapy is a good
good tool to use throughout your life
you don't need to do it all the time but
you know just something to bounce it off
of somebody for someone to hear the
crazy in your head what you think is
nuts and they go yeah it's not that
crazy everybody does that what are you
talking about do this do that it's
[__] fantastic clear your head a
little bit I feel like that's what's
directed at me instead of turning to the
hooch uh getting started is easy just
take a quick survey about your
preferences and better help will match
you with a licensed therapist if you're
the first therapist isn't a perfect fit
you can easily switch at any time at no
extra charge that's a big thing about
better help you get in the pool early
and then you figure it out but it's boom
get in the pool is the hardest part just
jump in with better help find more
balance with better help visit
betterhealth.com garbage today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com garbage betterhelp.com
garbage do a gang fix yourself there you
go okay let's talk about Consortium
shout out to the short Kings out there
and queens we love you shout out to the
short kings and queens out there this
goes out to you baby number one with a
bullet do yourself a favor ever wish you
were a little bit taller consory as you
covered yep Consortium makes comfortable
and stylish shoes that make you up to
2.8 inches taller and as everybody knows
2.8 inches goes a long way God damn
right advice the height is built into
the shoe so nobody's got to know your
business yeah the Styles they sell for
every occasion so you never have to be
six foot at the bar but five foot nine
at your work party because they got you
covered whether you're at the bar Bebop
and Scat and Diddy bopping or you're at
a work party Soiree whatever it is they
got you covered stock up on all
Consortium styles to continue living
your lie no matter what's on the
schedule if you're talking about living
lies welcome to the show Gang yeah
um the Brand's name the brand name is
even hit on the shoes in the packaging
that's how comedic consory is to helping
you stand a little taller come on what a
good group of peeps for a limited time
only our listeners get an extra 15 off
your order with code garbage at
consory.com the site is already 30 off
and with our code you get an extra 15
off 45 off your entire order Jesus she's
giving them away show up support our
show and check them out at consory
c-o-n-z-u-r-i.com and use the code
garbage consory.com code garbage when I
want to get high I don't turn to the
little I put on a pair of consorties
there you go
the show
and my mom was like really she was
building computers at the time okay my
mom was a very smart lady very high
class and
it's like she's a she's a history
Professor now really I was gonna ask you
what did she do when you were young oh
she was she worked man my mom worked
worked yeah okay at first my mom had two
jobs and went to school and I didn't
know that she was going to electronics
because my mom used to build mainframe
computers okay I'm saying and this and
then she they used to run like you know
before fiber optics they used to run
them through coal lines I'm saying which
is a weird thing my mom it was a
registered nurse she was yeah my mom
just she was doing it worked we got
working and so she's always done
something so if I bring up right now
about my mom fighting
she has [__] Amnesia my mind
but she forgets that I was with her from
the time that she was 20 years old sure
I've been with you your basically your
own adult life yeah and my sister has
been with us since she was 18. he was
saying she almost said 18. so we have
been there when you wasn't as mature as
you are now yeah woman
and my mom she acts like we like we like
we making up [__] on her I'm like Mom
remember you um slapped that lady in
Kmart parking lot she's like
it's like I have no recollection
I believe the fifth so you think I'm
just making it like a politician
testifying in front of Congress Kmart
you just I'm just thinking making up
Kmart yeah like you slapping the lady in
Kmart is making it up she's like I have
no idea what you're talking about right
by the popcorn
so specific I said Mom remember that
lady slapped me behind a donut and you
came home and beat the [__] out that
lady she was like what are you what are
you what are you referring to and I was
on vacation now why are you bringing it
up now no because I wanted everybody
know what type of person that you that
you like why I'm like I am sure yeah my
mom this lady
um was babysitting us and my mom told me
after I finished all my children I could
have had his donut
and this lady said that I couldn't and
I'm like no my mom said I could have it
so I'm eating a donut and the lady comes
in and slaps me
and back then we had a rotary phone and
I remember calling my mom's job and the
next thing I know I just heard
[__] we live in apartments and that's
how hard my mom stopped that we lived in
apartments and we heard her
he's dropping die about everybody
[Laughter]
oh I can't have the donut
[Music]
and Drug her down the step we had cement
steps in these apartments she's drugging
on the steps and she came back up and
told my sister now you got to watch him
[__] and then went back to work
I'm on my lunch break right now yeah my
mom my mom was a beast damn that's all
right and like I remember I'm like I I
could like she had grandkids now so she
don't ever want her grandkids to know of
course sure type of person she would and
I'm and I would always say hey man I
tell my son listen man if I would have
did this my mom would have beat the [__]
out of me and he'd be looking like
Grandma
a sweet old lady she would never do that
not Grandma and I'm like yo listen man
you don't know your grandmother like I
know your grandma
you calling everybody you call your mom
she comes over and beats them up
they spent all this time together and
and she does like my mom is in a
different position than she was when she
was of course with me like she took him
to Spain right like they in Spain for
like two months damn and they hanging
out because he speaks Spanish and she
want to re-emerge him and and so we we
hang on I come back this is your son
this is my son okay so they went over to
Spain for two months recently yeah last
year nice yeah all right no year before
last okay yeah like this lady here
was she is really big on this boy like
I'm like you know you never like I went
to Liberty Land in in Memphis like I
didn't go to Spain like I was two months
yeah I don't even think I had a goddamn
passport and all like we like we used to
fly and this it kind of make you what I
think now
it makes me hate flying really because
of how I I'm flying back when
planes really had real thing like I was
on Pan Am and I was on TWA I was on
these different and we had real meals
and I used to always wonder if I'm back
here in the back getting a leg quarter
mashed potatoes this one they would
always go back then peas and carrots
were always together they like even in
in like
um uh the oven meals sure it was always
together right they're using carrots so
if I'm thinking I got a leg quarter
mashed potatoes peas and cares a Coke I
get the full Coke like what do they have
in the first class you know that's what
I used to think but now
I'm in first class and they not having
[__] in the back or in the front right
like
it was a more more sophisticated way to
travel back then it was it was smoking
not everybody could afford it yeah do
you know what's crazy I remember you do
that the planes in the armrest they had
assets and it was I remember this man I
never get this guy because it's like yo
maybe the so your memory is so vivid he
had this thick black mustache like um
what's my guy from Magnum PI what was
his name the Tom Selleck right and he
was in with these little round glasses
and I never forget him packing his
packing his I knew a cigarette smoke
cause my mom smoked biscing has menthols
in the box and so we had he packing them
anything
a young man where would you be going
and I and I and I searched my sister I
was like he is cool as [__] that's like
a Pan Am commercial
man where might you be going I'm like
that's a commercial for sigs that's a
commercial for flying he was at
mustaches
[Laughter]
Burt Reynolds Oh man yeah how old are
you at the time no right now oh 49 49 so
I'm 40. I'm 47. so that was yeah that
was remember Bert on the Baskin rug
Burt Reynolds Tom Selleck is Billy D
Williams yeah Billy D Williams yeah hold
on ability to watch that that's a comic
I'm I'm sitting there I just talked to
him Julie Washington is the comic my
fault
he's also very good looking though yeah
they were all right back then man it's
good stuff all right we're because we're
going to ask you when did you get your
passport that's a big question yeah it's
a big question how old were you when you
got your passport 20
28. okay it was late in the later in the
game where were you going I was going to
Brazil okay okay for a vacation work no
we was shooting this movie over there
called
um this is very independent we this is a
very independent movie Brazilian butts
three I wish
I've seen one and two I damn sure wish I
was in three I'm a big fan I could I
could if if some of this footage that we
that we did not put in the movie would
have got out of this damn show his
position
but Brazilians part three
um we just shooting a call live from Rio
it was a it was a I think we was trying
to be the first like group of traveling
guys okay to go and shoot a movie
Somewhere in a different country that
was the that was the goal
um
we it was 10 of us we went to Brazil and
had a good time we went doing Carnival
you know are they good and crazy and
this is uh right after we came off of um
this thing called um the Kappa beach
party it's a big thing that happens down
in Galveston and it is huge it like
people heard of like the Atlanta
Freaknik this was way better really than
Atlanta freaked like way way better yeah
Capital beach party and it was all you
had to do was find the U-Haul it like it
this is very unorganized just like it it
we didn't have you just get a hotel room
you go down to Galveston and it's going
to be a lot of ladies walking around
with very skimpy bikinis on and a lot of
dudes out there with no shirts on oiled
up trying to impress the ladies with
small bathing suits on and then you add
a DJ on top of a U-Haul and this [__]
goes crazy so he's on top of the YouTube
and it goes down damn
sounds like a good time
great time huh okay other vacations as a
kid what would you where would you guys
go would you go anywhere
we would just go visit family go visit
family Mississippi Chicago New York
um L.A mostly driving or would you would
you be flying flying you'd be flying my
mom my mom but we we
my mom would work really hard in order
to get us places and I think we didn't
need vacations when did she start doing
start doing good with the career that
she wanted like was that she was going
to school for oh man
I think we were living because she when
she wasn't I think 83 I'm gonna say 83.
okay how old were you ten okay yeah
yeah because I remember I came back to
Houston in 1983.
um my mom was a very responsible person
when she felt like she couldn't
take care of us and we wasn't in the
best position she would send us to live
with other family members okay which you
know we're doing pretty well and I come
from a family which I am the only
unachiever in my family like on my
mother's side every person went to
college okay every person had something
like my mom my mom has a master's degree
like she my sister has a masters I have
um the one that was fighting yeah all
right my sister my the fighter is
probably in the two percentile of
intelligent people on this planet really
and she's a [__] genius all right
retired Navy okay in all type of special
ops and maybe my sister is a is a
serious
woman like her husband is a lieutenant
colonel just retired um
she raised all six of her children her
husband six kids they never went to
school all of them are home school and
three of them graduated from college two
of them getting ready to go no kidding
she's a [__] genius home school look
at that homeschooling like my sister is
right now my sister's in Thailand
teaching English
huh that's not homeschooled the way you
were homeschooled he didn't go to sixth
seventh grade for some reason yeah he
just stopped sitting around watching
daytime TV
watching The View and [__]
hey man a little Charisma goes a long
way dude like my kids are homeschool are
they yeah who does it you have a tutor
like somebody come in or you do it yeah
someone comes in and does it I started
and then you know I'm on the road so
they finished up yeah of course all of
in all of them are homeschool the only
one that wasn't homeschooled is my my
older kids and
my my daughter is a chef she has a
masters in whatever food science yeah oh
very learned people learning people
everybody seems to have a [__]
master's degree my dad even though he
didn't go to
um College anything my dad owned a
carrier service like in the early 70s
where he would they you know they didn't
have fax machines and all that so he
would carry all his legal papers between
sure attorney offices gotcha and they
and they would money as well which they
had these bags with the keys on the
zipper Keys yeah like Bank bags so I
love those things which led him into
um selling cocaine
it's a lateral move I think he was
insane because like back then powdered
cocaine the only people who was doing
was like attorneys bankers and [__] yeah
right so he was like I'm a carrier I got
money and alternative I got the
clientele like hey why not dude
this is in the 80s and this this is
this is still when it's in the vials
it's going in the brown vials so this is
you gotta and I would watch him
take the little and and dip in the vow
and then and then he'll he'll have like
all these vows and they had it was
different sizes it was like four
different size vials
[__] crazy your dad sounds like the
coolest dude in the world he's [__]
people up he's got his suit he's trying
to get laid he's moving he's moving blow
oh all Taylor Made suits she's got all
that coke money
it was
a lot of philosophies about things he
owned one pair of jeans two pair of
khakis and then maybe 70 TaylorMade
that's a joke that is a [__]
gentleman huh albums of my Ollie's
Ollie's Roper boots all these loafers
and my dad was uh these are different
dude and I remember he had this old
school he had this German he had four
calls right he had a Z28 he had um but
the IROC Z28 the IROC Z28 oh [__] he had
the um
it comes with the job you guys are
younger it's hard to describe how
popular those are yeah
from seeing it in movies they're nuts
yeah and then he had he had a motorcycle
he had a um he had drove a goat he had a
Gold Wing motorcycle he had this little
Toyota that he would do his deliveries
in
um the kid for the character and then he
had this car that was from Germany right
at the time it was only like four of
them in the United States and him and
his guy used to meet up to see where
they can get parts from and all they're
like yo man why you just can't take this
car to a regular place oh this is a
German car can't get the parts yeah and
it's like I'm like man why they even
have this car he's like and and then he
when he got rid of that car he got the
best car in the world that I thought was
the sexiest car in the world he had a
Peugeot oh yeah it was it's this royal
blue in the the insides was tan leather
that [__] car was he had good taste
that's his 80s is again a Peugeot
and I remember when he got rid of the
pujo that was like gray Poupon when it
had yes and then what do you know what
to do you know he was pronouncing it
wrong yeah they didn't know I didn't
even pronounce it right and then he got
his other car that it was just as
equally as [__] Upper Crust he got a
sob and this is what he stopped now is
fancy and he would only wait he I knew
man do you understand he was when he got
the SOB he will pull up and he would you
would hear Sade just blasted
y'all like he sounds smooth as [__]
I'm sure he kept the car as Immaculate
man yeah yeah I can picture them he had
the um
I thought it was only for the motorcycle
but he actually had one for every car
and they was different he had the covers
to tarp yeah over he had this tan one
that he would put over over there and
then he had this the blue one for the
motorcycle just
um he was Magnum P.I Jesus Christ let me
tell you the crazy thing with my pops so
he had a wreck on his bike okay he um
and I remember that day he had his jeans
on he was going to ride and he he would
walk back in the house he said man I
just feel like I need to put my Leathers
on
so he had his jacket on he had his boots
had his gloves helmet he gone and then
maybe two hours later there's a a tow
truck pulling in front of the house
he
that he saw um he tells me that a huge
piece of wood like a two by four was in
the was on the freeway and when he got
over from behind this truck he got over
he didn't know it was there so boom he
hit it and he
went down and he slid off the exit
and I said man why are you not why are
you not all [__] up you come on oh man
I just sat out on the bike and let the
bike slide off and so you're sitting
down on a wrecked bike this time
you just sliding off and and he's
talking to me as if nothing is wrong if
that's normal yeah like he's he's cool
even in a [__] motorcycle accident so
they taking the bike off the off the
thing and he walks in the house and I
I'm behind him and I noticed I said hey
um do you know your pocket of your jeans
I thought he said what and then he
reached back and he said oh I didn't
throw a piece of my ass out
you don't know that you got a chunk of
your ass missing like because it was a
piece of his butt was missing where he
was sliding and it was like it was like
the corner of his wallet was was
scratched up his jeans and then his butt
and I was like and he had to go get some
stitches
he didn't even know like I said man you
probably bled in the tow truck man
my dad's like I was like 11. he's like
yeah man oh it's nothing to it baby
everything's all right
based off of that uh What uh how many
suits do you have now
yeah let's do some cues here
oh man
it's a shame it's probably 30.
that's the classiest answer we've ever
had man that's a first yeah 30. and I
assume you know how to tie a tie bow tie
in a tie you know how to tie a bow tie
really yep huh man you might have the
wildest backstory but you might be the
classiest guy ask God damn you wanna tux
what's the house like now you're you're
in Houston
nice house I presume you're doing what
you're doing well of course of course
nice house
[Laughter]
okay 30 suits
what's the closet like walk-in situation
walking you got it yeah
um I have um a very nice closet I got it
done by um California collages I used to
work for Rich guys that's very [__]
California Closets is the highest
those checks
checks heavy checks you cut the
California Closet Mommy
here we go
you can tell that he actually worked
with him he's like no that's a nice
thing I used to have to I used to I used
to do bookkeeping for Rich guys and I
would have to cut their checks and they
all got they all buy a place and get
California Closets to come in and a
[__] heavy bike checks had to go out
to California and this is probably more
impressive then not only so I got my my
closet the upstairs the upstairs
bookshelves the closet in my son's room
the closet in my daughter's room and
then I had them come and do the shelving
for the garage they did all that yeah
he's doing all right it is very nice
yeah they do good work right here people
pull into my garage they're like well
that was [__] isn't that such a flex
though doesn't that feel good you're
like I'm coming through the garage
dude and then you know because um the
lady who lived in my house she um
she she has a non-profit organization
okay yeah she lives there yeah the lady
who lives in my house okay you know they
say that she's a wife yeah he that's
what he calls his wife I picked up all
right all right all right the lady who
lives in my house has a
non-profit organization called Mary Kay
so um she says Mary Kay and it's very
non-profit that is a cold that is
[__] cold blooded dude
profit
[Laughter]
she lives
I'm using that
it's all right
sure you're not wrong you are not wrong
and
um so
my the reason why we in this house is
because my mom was looking for a home
because she wanted to get out of that
condo and she kept coming by my house
saying oh it's so nice over here and I
and I I told the lady who lives in my
house I said hey I think my mom what's
this house
and so
we found another house three minutes
away damn we packed up everything moved
to that house and I called my mom over
to my house
and she's like nobody's here I'll say
just just go in the house open the door
and she goes in did y'all move
I'm like yeah so you can move in damn
and yeah so I gave my mom my first house
and holy [__] the scene from American
Gangster yeah dude yeah that's [__]
wrong no [__]
yeah look at you damn just got her the
house here you go gave her the house and
then she asked me to remodel the kitchen
I said what type of thing
and then you asked me to remodel a
kitchen yeah no just no down payment no
escrow money
who are these California Closet people I
keep hearing about
[Laughter]
holy [__] man talk about a comma that's
a boss move let's [__] go okay
um in the in the bedroom uh king
mattress king king California okay his
and her sinks in the in the bathroom he
isn't her thing you got the shower
separated Source how many car garage we
looking at just two two okay I wish it
could be the next house because I'm
buying some I'm buying some property
and um I want a cause we have upstairs
and downstairs now I want a 5 000 square
foot flat one floor one floor that with
little levels to it inside but get it
built from the ground up because
I'm buying a land how come you want to
do on one floor the stairs I don't
stairs I don't want to keep doing the
mistakes just thinking about down the
line down the line yeah sure smart and
so the property in the back I have
I've mapped this probably it's like 2.8
Acres okay and so I got it pretty mapped
out the house in the front and then I
want a um a greenhouse like maybe uh 90
30 90 feet okay 34 wide
um Greenhouse I can grow all the stuff
we want to grow and because I get y'all
to trying to find um seeded watermelons
because I don't eat
non-seated water you don't need seedless
water yeah seedless watermelon how come
just because they're genetically
engineered a genetically engineer I'm
like what what the hell is that like
I'm not that up across but I can't just
spit out the damn thing that's a hard
stance but I like it yeah so I've never
heard of someone who doesn't like them
yeah I love them because they might use
Daryl what the genetic what they do to
do that that chemical make you sterile
oh [__] really and I I like children
told me we're building a greenhouse
maybe I start eating when I'm 55.
and I just want to I want a little
compound where I can just go love that
and sure because man we're doing let's
say doing um covert right I had covered
for like 32 days damn and
I had to stay in a hotel
and I had to pay for it myself no
reimbursement from the government or
nothing like she said do it myself
because everybody was at your house
family was at your house you got it so
yeah I had to go cool right
but it was people who
I knew in other places that had covert
and my buddy was calling me with covert
like yeah you in the hotel and I'm
fishing on my pond because he has all
this land like nine acres if you have
like a little guest house or something
like that so he was
he at covet his family was in the front
house he's in the house that they have
that's off in the woods like he Off the
Grid on his own land he's chilling yeah
she's on vacation he's hunting he's
fishing he's coughing but he's by
himself he's like and it was it was
insane I was like you know something
I wanna I wanna piece of this this yeah
planet where I can just go and shut it
down and just do whatever I want to do
and buying land and on the land is the
best way to do it okay
I like you growing anything now do you
guys have vegetables growing at the
house now I haven't I've been on the
road and I haven't been able to do it
that's why I'm getting this greenhouse
okay when I was growing things really
regular
the lady who lived in the house has a
problem with coming outside turn on the
damn sprinkle system and so I would come
back and to either
you the birds have eaten all my tomatoes
um it's a raccoon who was like really
sampling my okra like he was like
like he was like oh the ones at the
bottom way better the ones at the doctor
he was like and it was uh it was it was
an opossum who was who was really into
zucchini and squash and cucumbers yeah
like and then the rest of it slugged man
it's the I was in the slowest War
with snails and slugs like
it was it was I was salting the ground I
was I was doing a lot you got to be on
top of it I was putting beer this day
like you gotta put the beer I was
putting like it was puddles I would cut
out things and have cans of beer and
they would just fall into the bed man
it's like these goddamn slugs knew they
was like no no no they start over there
let's learn let's go around it's like
they was using the fence
like it was crazy and then the plague
happened I had no idea
that I was living in this Zone where all
these caterpillars and worms migrated
through before this before these houses
were there oh [__] they would just come
this probably doesn't stay they normal
thing my God my garden was
with the best it ever been
I'm weak going out there we eating food
we oh and then the plague comes they
come through
jammed up decimated my garden in a night
yeah
and you couldn't stop because they were
all on the houses it was like it was it
was like a billion of them I'm like
yeah the greenhouse Greenhouse but like
my mom is in that house now she grows
everything oh gosh my mom had a
butterfly garden out there now she has
all sorts of food out there when I buy
something I'll take it over there like
can you do it and she for some reason
she has managed to avoid the plague it's
like she she has all this stuff and then
she um she has a lot of bird feeders so
the birds come and just sit there and
wait on caterpillars
flies mosquitoes and things and the the
like I told them the gangster of a
garden what you need in the garden you
need ladybugs sure ladybugs are like the
bullies of a garden really and if you
buy them
they will leave
if you put felt out there they they love
they love that so you grow felt they'll
come and they're just sit in the garden
it's crazy we my brother gardened last
year that's why I asked you very classy
thing to be gardening he was growing
weed
good
Good Greenhouse no big for that
um but we started this year uh with the
with a couple tomato plants so we have a
couple tomato plants and sure as [__]
maybe like a week ago I'm up there in a
ladybug lands on me I'm like oh what's
this and I put it over in a thing
there's a bunch of ladybugs that live on
my on our tomato plants that are that
are flying around and that's keeping all
the rest of the burger very classy to be
gardening gardening is very clear he's
got 30 suits the classiest guy ever met
it's crazy I remember when I when I got
out the street so I'm not in the streets
no more and
maybe I'm gonna say about seven years
ago
me and my I had a altercation with
somebody and I went to go see one of my
old friends and he has this huge Garden
and we talking about the situation and
he said man I sure hope that this works
out
and um that y'all can Rectify this
situation because
it turns to be just like this then
I would prefer not to bury anything in
my garden
Jesus Christ
I just planted strawberries man
I'm I'm uh we gonna get it together he
said yeah hopefully so
Jesus if I if I had to get involved
and I just said I said man even in your
old age you still very menacing
in a garden you just seem to be very
medicine and gone into my yeah but um
can I get you
to step off my arugula
[Laughter]
because they man you grow lettuce
grow lettuce yeah it's crazy huh you can
grow it in a bucket
really I'm going in a bucket and lettuce
comes up we're very cultured it's crazy
if you're a homeowner tonight
you definitely got to start doing that
we haven't closed yet okay
the bank and she'll still shut this
whole thing down
I'm with that with that property I I was
45 days out of clothes on this property
then one of the relatives dies
they have to sell this property because
their grandmother the lady who
originally owned a property between all
our kids she's she put in her will but
they had where they had to sell it
because she actually didn't want the the
war the fight right now so
one of them dies now they gotta I had to
go back and amend and then what another
thing that happened the the
um the title company gets shut down for
some sort of Fraud and right before we
had to move all our money to the to
another title company to be caught up in
that lawsuit and I would lose that
earnest money I mean it's been a it's
been ordeal so now I'm probably maybe
another 60 days out of closing on that
property on the new one on the new
property takes forever takes for and I
thought we was done didn't this guy
decides he want to pass he want to pass
and sets it into a whole other motion of
if his kids got something to do with me
just sell me the damn property damn and
this is just the land there's no homes
there's nothing on adjustable just the
land and it's that's the hardest thing
to get a loan on and this is two acres
you bought
2.84 you ain't gonna let you forget that
I'd start calling that three by the way
yes and I and I already have it because
I've looked at it so much that I got it
um broken up to my for my kids every kid
to own a portal plot of this land so and
I own the center part there's a corner
of everybody's name so nobody can sell a
land without me at all because I own the
end Corner this guy's playing chess yeah
you're like a Rockefeller a Dupont
[Laughter]
then the DuPont's got to be the coldest
goddamn family in American history oh
yeah everybody looks over the dude while
they were throwing the Kennedys and
everybody else knows that's why they're
quietly just [__] stacking cheddar
and killing people they got their own
State yeah yeah Delaware they got
Delaware Delaware online I think you I
don't think you can be into in Delaware
without being a Dupont it's like they've
married cousins
for sure marry a Dupont cousin so that's
what you're going for
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you I've heard about them
they got long money those guys you know
um it's somebody somebody hit me with
the with the it it was crazy you get to
a point where people think that you
making enough money to start to even
include you in certain conversations hey
um because I know maybe like 15 years
ago there's no way somebody would have
called me instead this like so boldly
look hey man it's um it's 10 acres in
this small town that's available 100 000
what you talking about doing
I was like talking about hanging up
right now
I'm like well let's let's go down and
look at it and I went down there to look
at the property and
I'm I'm not ready for
what I would have to do because it's 10
acres of Royal rural land like there's
no it's nothing knock down trees cover
up swamps whatever the [__] you got the
pipes in all that stuff build your I
mean dig a whale put electricity in and
I'm thinking
not ready
but then last month I was like
I met a guy
at a hat we had a hat he's playing
Monopoly down there dude I'm just
Gathering off Acres left and right I'm
at a hat store that sells these really
nice hats
I mean this guy talking and he's like
he's down there in Texas got the bushes
nervous yo um you know you know I build
you know I'm like you build from scratch
like yeah yo we clear landing on the
thing hey man what it well if I had like
10 acres of rule like what would it oh
we would do the bulldozer I said well
gave me his card and we've been in talks
I'm like I said let me close on this and
then I'm thinking 10 acres I can let it
sit there as long as I own it and I I
want to get another business partner but
then I'm that's a family member versus
something I was gonna say we'll throw in
a couple of hundred give us a little I
got two grand on it let me let me wet my
beak on this yo so so just say say you
get this land right
and you take
you and you break it up and you sell two
of the Acres yeah you know to something
to somebody and then you take two acres
and you and you build a bunch of tiny
homes for people to be able to live in
that's kind of like you know it's you
you take me home but you kind of rule a
little bit you are and so now you own a
like a nice little Community yeah you
are a Dupont you're a super smart rich
guy that's what's going on that's what
we're getting to like I'm you're yeah
I'm looking at because I I know me I'm
not gonna do stand up
forever I'm probably gonna retire and
I've been saying 25 20 20 25 but I'm
thinking more like 26 because I'm we're
gonna probably announce the theater tour
um for 2024 because we'll probably do
two two years of that and then lay it
down people like why would you do that
because at some point when you start
touring a lot
you become restless and I didn't know
what that meant but I jump up and I'm
already where I'm supposed to be and
that and that's a that's a uneasy
feeling like if I go on vacation
I have to go for at least three weeks
because the first week you can't shut it
down oh oh I gotta I gotta be so you
know how what it's like to be on the
resort and you thinking I got to be here
at this time I gotta be here this time
like no I don't have to be anywhere sure
I have the same three weeks
yeah what's it what what do you like to
do on vacation what's a vacation now
yeah a vacation now is
me and my children and the lady who live
in my house just you bring her with you
good good guy going somewhere this so
after this after this press run I leave
here Thursday
I'm technically done I'm technically
done for until July after the Fourth of
July I go to Oklahoma on the seventh the
seventh the sixth seventh and 8th I'm
not doing a show until then and
I started a tour in January of January
the second week of January first week of
January and we haven't shut it down
until now so
I'm technically off until after the
Fourth of July so when I go back
and I'm going to do some stuff around
the house and then I'm gonna do what
I've been wanting to do is pop in on
some
comedic friends you know like that's
that's has always been a thing like
because guest spots I want to bring back
what a real guest spot so funny I was
thinking about that today
like this was this is a guest spot
I'm in Nashville maybe two months ago
I'm getting ready to do this show and
Ricky Smiley was like yo hey I'm gonna
come see you and I'm like cool and I'm
thinking about my mind as soon as you
get here I'm putting his ass to work as
soon as he get up soon
as soon as you get in so Ricky Combs and
the the the middle is on
and I was like hey Ricky you want to go
out and do something he's like sure so I
go out and I said usually I wouldn't
start my show like this y'all but yeah I
got a special guest who want to say
something big shout out to Angela
Johnson in the building big shout out to
Marvin hunting the bill in the building
Marcus D Wiley blame um Miss Pat is here
but one of my friends want to come out
and say something y'all get up for Ricky
Smiley Ricky comes out and does like 10
minutes I'm in the back I'm kicking it
and then he does 10 minutes and then
brings me out
and I'm like that's a [__] game
that's fun yeah
it's not like some dude that asked hey
let me go do this but you're not a guest
spot they don't [__] know you're an
intruder yeah like you're you're
intruding on yourself
that has you if that's like old-timey
entertainment [__] it's like ah this
other person's here pop in yeah it's
very I also like the move of you going
out and breaking so the feature was
bringing you out like you were gonna go
ahead line you go out listen special
special guest yeah he comes out does
this thing you go back and hang then you
come back out yeah that is awesome
that's the classiest guy you're the
classiest dude I've ever met in my life
man hopefully not because I know some
real dirt bags I'm rich oh so I'm gonna
pop in on um on both of my guys
um I'm gonna pop in on DL in the next
couple weeks and then I'm gonna pop in
on Bill Bellamy I already got I already
know what I'm popping on Bill you're
just gonna pop in I'm Gonna Pop I
already talked to to the road imaginary
thing he out they already know how he
know everybody know I'm coming but Bill
so bill is probably gonna this is what
it's gonna sound like he's probably
gonna be in the green room and I'm gonna
show about after he gets there and when
the show starts because I used to be the
original host of his ladies night out to
him okay I'm gonna go up
who they introduce
yourself they're going to introduce
whoever they want to introduce I'm gonna
be the person walk over on the stage and
play Oh pardon me well one second let me
take this and bill is going to be in
that green room he's gonna like
know that boy
I love that and I'm gonna bring up
whoever he's whoever's supposed to be
the horse I'm gonna bring up whoever's
supposed to be the middle and then I'm
gonna bring him up and I know Terence is
Terence is over the moon that I called
him I said that my flight information
everything Tara's like oh no he's
[__] really coming and I'm like yeah
I'm coming I don't have nothing to do
that weekend it's so cool and then after
the week after that I'm popping up on DL
and I'm like hey I'm here man this guy's
got it all figured out I know he's
really the really cracked the [__]
code this guy um one of the coolest guys
I ever met I just think that it's a a
cool ass thing man to it's fun yeah be
able to go somewhere and and I would do
this with any comic if I'm in town and I
see you guys performing I'ma come to the
show if you want me to do something cool
yeah
want you to [__] really make me hurt
my [__] deep hey ladies and gentlemen
one of the most prolific storytellers of
all time who's gonna hand me my ass and
eat my lunch oh he's a dick everybody
man Foley's gonna come out and do 20
minutes on ozempic
you know don't come to our shows
you sound like somebody else I'm not
gonna say they name I'm not gonna say
today
and he said he said I was he said man
this is my fault just told him I call it
a bomb threat
I'm in the green room and I'm and I'm
minding my own business we talking and
he says I'll leave one you wanna do
something I said cool and he's he he
said he said I'm not gonna [__] you
I only extended it because courtesy
because you was here but I actually
wanted you to say [__] no yeah
exactly
I'm in my shoes I'm going to work baby
he said yo and when you went up I turned
to my manager said this is the [__]
worst decision yeah
no he's going like because I don't even
tell him how much to do or nothing and
he's like he's gonna [__] up he's gonna
[__] bury me he's like Ali's classy
he's not going to do that he said his
romance told him he's like not at least
class he's not going to do that I did
like three minutes
and then I then I I
ended with a a nice one and then I
brought him up right on the Roar
and he was like after the show he was
like I was [__] using it because it
was like you walked out they [__]
loved you as soon as you walked out and
then I'm like why do they know him
you're up there doing 25 just burying
them I'm I'm with a with any show you in
the show forget the picture you guys
have been great I'll see you next time
I'm in Arkansas thank you they're
dropping checks what the [__] I got
t-shirts I gotta move
hey man you
then you you ain't over then they go up
there and close your show good night
fireworks are going oh [__] and like um
I guess it's over yeah
but we gotta get you out of here man
thank you dude thank you so [__] much
it's an hour that's an hour that's over
an hour yeah so much fun man man you
know one of the classiest guy crazy
story crazy upbringing one of the
craziest upbringings do one of the
classiest turnarounds It's [__]
amazing yeah my mom um would would have
um tablecloths even though we lived and
not so desirable situation just like I
don't know put the tablecloths on like
for what like I can see where you get a
cheese fancy your dad had your dad had a
lot of class man you know what's what's
weird but when I look back on it my dad
my mom and my dad did have
a lot of different
things that you wouldn't see in a normal
neighborhood or my dad was like my mom
drove a Camaro like the original Camaro
it was great with this burger it was
burgundy inside and I you know how
people say you don't want your mind to
come to the school because they'd be
dressed crazy my mom I'll never forget
my mom came to the school one time I was
in I was in trouble and she had on a
[__] mink she had on a mink jacket
and with this with this really sassy
dress and I remember I was like I don't
I don't ever want you to come up here
again Pam Grier
I think my mom got this big curly hair
bro she's short she's brown skin and my
mom is gorgeous I'm like no no I don't
want I don't want you coming up here and
I remember this boy called my mom a fox
your mom is a fox I'm like you don't get
the [__] out of here
hell you know second year or second
grade and over the goddamn foxy you just
see the car door open the cigarette hits
the ground a stiletto just puts the
cigarette
because you smoked a long busy heads and
menthols in the boxes and that's why I
always always say it like that because
she always made sure get the missing
missing his Menthol in the Box because
she didn't ever want a soft pack yeah
sure I don't want my cigarette box is
classic to get crushed in my purse so
she would always have the box I'm like
it's crazy down refined woman ladies and
gentlemen the special out right now the
domino effect dude lost on his YouTube
page you gotta check it out he's touring
yes
you gotta see him Ali siddique everybody
anything else you want the folks I
didn't know yeah
whatever I don't man I think I don't
even have anything else besides the I
maybe I have some books
I turned the first domino effect into a
book so it comes out of June 27th okay
um then I have some some you know
merchandise or whatever but the biggest
thing is pushing domino effect two I
think it's a a really really good
project is it has a message to it that's
why it's called Lost and helping people
cope with a lot of things that they you
know come sometimes people get decimated
over a loss sure totally destroyed
whether it's a girlfriend whether it's a
job whether it's you know losing a mind
you know because only I go through a lot
of different things so
hopefully you know people gravitate
towards it dude it's absolutely
fantastic thank you yeah you are one of
the best folks if if you don't know you
gotta you got to check them out he's
unbelievable yeah buddy we can't thank
you enough and um always big shout out
big R.I.P hopefully resting very very
well Chris cotton yeah shout out to the
big dog of course yeah Kitty what do you
got for him uh we're all uh are you
garbage tickets merch the whole nine
yards we'll be all over the road thanks
a lot guys we appreciate it okay we're
in my garbage that's the classiest
[__] guy I've ever seen in my life oh
my God I'm not building Greenhouse I got
30 [__] suits
I think you're taking over what are you
talking about cutting your checks gag we
love you we'll see you next week